c'est vraiment un objectif c'est
vraiment un objectif très important il
faut dégager les marges de manoeuvre
pour nos priorités on parlera tout à
l'heure de défense on parlera on peut
pas dire aujourd'hui qu'on est en guerre
et laisser nos armées sont les budgets
qui sont nécessaires donc il est
nécessaire de faire des économies de
diminuer la dépense publique pour
infecter un certain nombre de dépenses
sur des priorités et donc je pense qu'il
faut vraiment te donner ce cap des 3 %
et puis quand on est européen ces règles
on l'a défini ensemble il faut assumer
ce qu'on a défini ensemble et donc là la
parole vis-à-vis de l'europe c'est
quelque chose qui compte pour nous pas
question d'aller re négocier non je
pense que moi j'aurais eu l'occasion de
le faire discuter avec l'union
européenne je pense qu'aujourd'hui dans
l'état de crise de l'europe il faut que
la france soit digne d'être un bon élève
de l'europe est de faire en sorte que la
les économies budgétaires qui sont quand
même non pas l'intérêt de l'europe mais
l'intérêt des français soit dans notre
non pas de drm magique déployés par a
pas de dérapage